foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to another very special episode
of Fight Night flashbacks with the main
man Eric Griffin here all right today's
a big one my man because I'm about to
say uh thank you for having me on these
uh I've learned a lot a lot of people
hitting me up about like this my
newfound Fascination and love for UFC I
I still find it very bloody and violent
and sometimes it's hard to watch but I'm
now appreciating like the chess of it
the uh there's a lot that goes into it
yeah there's a lot that goes into it the
skill the and then the mental stuff to
it so it's very it's very fascinating
sport these are fun for me man I never
really get to break down or talk about
fights like this usually on balls deep
and some you know yeah undercard fight
on the job show for the hardcore so this
is fun for me because you know also you
can see how you know back in the day
like Dick Cheney was like oh this is
human [ __ ] fighting or whatever I think
it was Dick Jenner one of the government
officials like this human [ __ ] fighting
if you're uneducated about fighting I
get it like you see two bloody guys with
the shirts off like and they're in a
cage like it's a lot but the more you
get informed about and how special these
athletes are the more respect you have
for it so if you don't know I know but
no mistake about it though this is still
it is a brutal violent
support oh yeah but there is something
there's something like about two people
fighting for their life I mean that's
just something that's been going on for
you know for a thousand years forever
there's something where there's
something we that we're attracted to
that that's what sports is even sports
that are unviolent sports like
basketball or whatever but even football
it's a violent sport you know what I
mean yeah but anyways so you know but uh
if you um kind of shy away or kind of
squint at the idea of uh blood and
getting people getting punched in the
face that's why I decided to bring this
next gentleman up because this dude you
know how you know I'm gonna relate this
to your comic book uh Obsession this is
this dude is the Carnage of the UFC he's
Carnage so this guy's name is hamzat
shamaya this is the new guy right and
he's now he's now undefeated he is the
Boogeyman from Sweden via chechnya he is
the scariest guy in the UFC D currently
and he is just a freaking tidal wave
he's like he's like the next big thing
okay so we're leading up to it because
the big the next big UFC pay-per-view is
hamzat who's like the young chechnyan
lion versus the old kind of Legend in
Nate Diaz Nate Diaz how old how much
older is one than the other oh Nate's 37
or 38 and I'm sorry wow
28 but like in his prime Injustice he's
such a Savage he scares me he I think he
can be a champion at 70 85 and 205 even
this dude and he's currently undefeated
he's undefeated so we're gonna start
here so because he has an interesting
kind of come up in the UFC so he debuts
against John Phillips at middleweight on
remember during the lockdown they were
doing fight Island oh can't do anything
let's take this to an island because no
one can mess with us there so he goes
there and he fights John Phillips and
starches them starches like chokes them
out everyone's like okay here we go he
stays on the island because he can get
touched he goes I'm just gonna stay here
and look for a fight because he goes
okay 10 days later he fights uh right
raise McGee McKee on fight Island
literally 10 days later so then the
Legend Starts to build right right he's
like who's this chechnyan Savage and
here we will kick off with this oh I'm
ready wait wait already but before we go
I gotta ask him about the some basic
questions what's his specialty man
[Laughter]
come out just
so is
he a jiu jitsu guy so anyone from like
Dagestan that you know that that Russian
area Dagestan chechnya they're gonna
have a uh their black belt and they I
think they call of combat sport like
World of Combat Sports so like sambos
big over there so literally like guys
like Monica Chev and khabib when I when
you and I were growing up me you know
playing whatever kickball tag they're
wrestling
for reals the wrestling and so the USC
knows this like there is a you know in
Game of Thrones I have a vision of
little kids on the yard and they're just
like all right I'll take a school of
bluff and this guy and then they're just
like ah you know it's hilarious you say
yard you mean on the Rocks like they
they live behind mountains there was no
grass no no they live on behind Mountain
like in the mountains so so khabib and
makshev would literally carry rocks up
the mountain when they're like five or
six years old just to prepare to choke
people out like it's just a different
level and they're take there's you know
in Game of Thrones say winners coming
dude Dage standings are coming so
there's no we gotta get better at
pronouncing their names so is that the
specialty then and what do you what what
specialty is that so he's like what is
he like you know so he's he's just like
a there's a there's a dangerous brawler
no no no he so their background's gonna
be heavy and wrestling grappling okay
but they're the anti-ju Jitsu because
they literally like khabib makshev the
homeboy here uh uh uh you might have
they just want to break you like they
don't want to knock you out they and
they'll take it Rocky they literally
want to just break you inside that
octagon I will break you it's not so
let's hit this you're gonna see this
dude is a different caliber like we
watch some good fights on this wow this
this guy is about to fight I mean I he
doesn't look intimidating this guy that
you know
but it but again it's first fight in the
UFC look at him talking to him picked
him up like a little baby yeah dude he
was picking goats up as a two-year-old
yes this white boy with tattoos you
think he's scared can you imagine he
picked him up and talked him to his ear
I'm about to kill you you know how
everyone goes I went mess with a guy in
a bar with cauliflower ears no no new
rule cauliflowers whatever anybody can
get that you don't mess with a guy with
that freaking dagistanian beard yeah
like you see somebody with that beard
you turn the other way
so he just mauls people dude just mauls
them to death
and this poor guy my first UFC fight hey
Mom tune in this is his first fight this
other guy oh man this is a tough one to
be their first fight he's just you're
just getting mauled to death yeah he
can't even get a
I don't even know what this other guy's
specialty is like he's not even here's
the thing he's probably he's probably
versed in Jujitsu I don't I don't think
he's a black belt but he's probably you
know I'd say purple maybe he's doing
shrimping getting out again these
dagestanians and chechenes they just
don't partake in they're like cool dude
so he he didn't allow him to even get
into a stance or anything warm up like
this has got to be really frustrating
for this guy on the bottom right now
like yo bro let me get up and like let
me get let me get let me get a slight
sweat before you jump on me yeah but
it's literally what they do and they eat
breathe sleep so Kids In America grow up
want to play in the NFL NBA these guys
grow up wanting to break people and it
is a problem it's a problem to the U.S
which you know we're going the complete
opposite way kids can't play tackle
football
um
like moms play tackle football and Vegas
okay but if you're if you're
if you're the girls Sports yeah
and they make fun of them
play a tackle football yeah well okay
you tackle like a girl oh CT
[Music]
so like if you're
you know like if you have like whatever
your specialty is yeah like how do you
how does someone prepare for someone
that like just wants to do this like
this doesn't even look like anything
like there's no fighting there's no no
there's no yeah it looks like MTV's
bully beat down yeah you're like what
this bully do and like oh no he's
actually professional and what's the ref
thinking right now the ref I mean this
is so unorthodox right this is not is
that a thing that's like uh that the is
that a Talk Amongst USC now they're like
damn how like
what is the counter to this
the counter would be someone who can
um match the pressure and get them on
their back foot so they can't come
forward and you'll see the LA I think
you saw his last fight he fought Gilbert
Burns I'm jumping a little ahead here
but just to answer your question so he
goes from fighting you know he fought
this guy in uh they call him the leech
uh jingling so he was ranked I think
maybe top 15 like 13 or area so he goes
literally starches everybody and then
you'll see goes okay here's the number
two guy in the world dude which is
unheard of dude this is like a big
brother fighting his little brother like
I'm you know like I'm surprised he
doesn't just grab his arms like grab his
arms and then you know go like this you
know you know what I mean you know how
you're yeah hitting yourself
that's what that looked like right there
he was like oh man you think this is
impressive one maybe in the next two or
three of these we do we gotta do khabib
because he's literally has this guy by
the wrist on the ground and he's going
just give up you know you know this is
my destiny just give up I don't want to
do this I don't want to do this he looks
at Dana he goes I need titles as easy
beating his ass he goes I need titles
you know I deserve title he's just
breaking dudes man so then so Gerald
Mercer is no punk yeah I'm about to say
I was just about to say I was just 44
fights veteran tough Grappler like this
dude you're like all right all right
Ham's hot let's see what you got
I'm not gonna tell you how this goes I'm
just gonna let you watch it look at him
excited eight no I like you know what I
like about this guy he wants to
challenge I I see it in his face I see
it in his demeanor they were born to do
it yeah the way we grow up look at him
look at him look at he's like oh he's
like he's he's like a tiger like ready
to pounce he's scared dude I wish there
was it seems like some break dancing
music should be playing right now
gotta be sick
everything went like this
church
just a big ass
and then throws it at the next guy so
now so this you're like all right all
right let's see what happens
how big that guy is compared to him it's
that middleweight to say 85. wow he
looks bigger than that he's bigger than
that oh yeah oh at least yeah right so
you're like damn Duke can grapple too
bigger guy it's gonna tough test for him
okay cool Eric
okay I'm gonna knock him out oh oh oh oh
what oh you thought I could only grapple
what
look at him we gotta go back yeah yeah
oh you're worried about just getting
taken down say less because I can I can
strike with the best of them all right
let's take a little break from chat with
my boy Eric filament on hamzat Nate Diaz
he has a lot to learn but my boy is
excited and I'm excited for that big
pay-per-view but let's take a little
break because the numbers don't lie the
last decade over four million people
have chosen my friends at SimpliSafe
home security to protect their cribs you
don't earn the trust of that many people
without doing something right and at
SimpliSafe your safety is the only thing
they care about I know because I use
SimpliSafe in my own home they protect
you with Cutting Edge security
technology powered by 24 7 Professional
monitoring agents who always have your
back here's why I love it man they take
care of you again 24 7 Professional
monitoring simply saves agents call you
the moment of threat is detected no
matter what it is they also dispatch
police or First Responders if it's an
emergency even if you're not home or
can't be reached they're sending them
man that's why I love them Simply Safe
blankets your home in protection with
Advanced sensors for every room kids
room Windows Doors HD security cameras
for inside outside your crib smarter
ways to detect motion that only alert
you when the threat is real and even
Hazard sensors that instantly detect
fires floods and other threats to your
crib the modern experts use an advanced
response technology to visually confirm
when a break-in is real so you can get
the highest priority police dispatch
that's right they work fast customize
the perfect system for your home in just
a few minutes you got a few minutes to
protect your home I think you do go to
simplysafe.com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus 20 off again go to
simplysafe.com shop there's no safe
place like SimpliSafe wow yeah it's
power too you think so then so you saw
so that was the second final fight
Island and then this is his third fight
so the first fight demolishes guy second
fight stays 10 days on the island then
after that they give a Merc chart and
you're like right here's the actual test
because he's destroying everybody and
this was the test and this is where the
legend of hamzat begins you're like this
has to be a tough test for me oh really
cool there you go okay there's your test
I mean all right here's my question this
other guy
you think he was preparing for I think
the other guy looked like he was
preparing for the guy's gonna Rush
breakdown thing because we didn't know
yet we really didn't know how like same
thing you were like oh this guy is you
know uh Sweden via chechnya like clearly
grappling's his thing and it is but they
didn't know like they can't be trains
within Sweden they have Gus Finn they
have monsters out there and the legend
that comes out of that camp they said
they've never seen them lose around in
sparring do you think that he prepared
for that like he prepared to be like do
you think that was planned or was it
just like on hamza's part yeah oh you
think that or or do you think it was
just an opportunistic uh uh opportunity
to punch or do you think that they
trained like I want you to I want you to
train to so you can get some hits in
dude what do you think yeah I think his
uh his team was like well he clearly
he's gonna be looking for the takedown
so if it's open you know get it done and
this is what's scared about him he has
the skills to do all that well most guys
it's tough to have those so so he
starches Gerald shot right and then he
gets coveted so it's it halts the the
chechnyan train it holds it because he
doesn't get like coveted like I had this
dude is messed up he's saying he can't
train he tried going back train too soon
his lungs his cardio's done there's talk
of even maybe retiring so you're like
damn dude this is gonna ruin him and
then finally he gets over it like all
right here's because you know he's on
this hot streak so he's undefeated at
this point 3-0 so like all right here's
uh jingling uh jingling Lee who the
nickname is the leech and he's you know
he floats around the top 15. you'll see
him uh he looks like chin on steroids
he's a tough character dude he's a very
tough character you know what's funny
I haven't seen a lot of you know Asian
descent Fighters and they're surprised
yeah when it comes to like I'm talking
about martial arts I know right what is
that about look at the head on this dude
looks like a Rottweiler but right and
again this supposed to be a tough test
for him this is also the first time uh
uh Jesus Christ look him just bragged
all in homeboy he's talking to Dan right
there look I'm talking to Dana look at
him Savage dude think to be inside that
octagon and have the wits while you're
in the middle dude we're 20 seconds in
to talk [ __ ] and look at your boss and
go what are we doing dude this is easy
what are we doing give me a top five guy
like well just just beat this guy up for
us he's like I'm doing it look at this
look on his face and again this guy's no
punk like he's one but before this fight
he's won four out of five well he's a
tough customer okay so the last time the
guy fought he he knocked that guy out
yep because I noticed when this guy came
out he came out looking to be like like
if this as if like oh we're gonna box
yep and then he was like remember I do
this yeah remember this is that so I
like that I like the um oh look at his
back he does uh he does that cup yeah
have you done that no it works it works
some guys swear by it just get to me it
gets the blood flowing in the areas that
are injured this has got to be okay tell
me in the mindset of like you're this
other guy your expertise is say look
obviously it looked like the guy was a
fighter you know it's like you're not
even able to the guy look just like chin
right there you're not able to do
anything he's Chinese this has got to be
what's going on how do you get out of
this It's just tough man you got to be
so Versed and grappling to get out of it
because I've said this all these
dagestanians chechnyans Russians so when
you're wrestling in America with the
wrestling we have chain wrestling and so
our best wrestlers in freestyler Greco
they might have especially when they're
going against a guy say just a normal
wrestler doesn't have the same pedigree
like an Olympian those Olympians you're
gonna be able to stop maybe the for like
the initial single leg or double leg but
they have nine to ten other tricks in
their tool bag to get you down that you
haven't seen and you're not prepared for
all right these dagestanians and
chechnyans have 50. there's no way to
stop it you know and I feel like the the
strategy here is don't let this guy get
on his feet again oh right his only goal
is to break you I I'd rather be knocked
out than deal with this yeah to me this
is way more embarrassing look at this
video
here you have he's been on his feet for
five seconds this whole fight and
exactly and in your town you're the
toughest guy nobody's even seen you face
down like this and look at this okay but
here's the thing I'm asking though
William choke out isn't this frustrating
look at him so you've seen him break a
dude you see him knock a dude out and
then now he's about to choke Chad out
but but
he's okay come on dude you got to give
up already yeah I mean that's in I mean
he's not even hand fighting at this
point which to me it's like what's the
defensive there he goes hand fighting
there but
should have done that a little earlier
shouldn't you just like just get off me
why does he do this you're gonna get
choked out and you're choked out you got
a hand fight like when you're punching
you're not fighting what's joking elbow
him in the rib look at him put him out
put them out oh [ __ ] I was about to say
what is the Wrath is a ref waiting for
the guy to tap out correct or if he's
always like sleepy stops uh well yeah
because a lot of guys uh you know
the fight till they go to sleep geez man
this is um this is so like like
how do you even prepare for that like
the guy's like
doesn't even allow you to don't give an
inch you're flailing around and like
that's got to be like the most
frustrating this has to be the most
frustrating thing now let me ask you
this and the so in the fight community
what do they what are they what is their
honest feeling about that fight style
like because it's like it doesn't seem
as if there's like like is there a
feeling of like come on man let's
actually fight no no so so that that's
like this kid's a problem okay so so
there's no respect okay okay
but I'm saying I I know we all respect I
respect that okay that's a respectable
fight style it's a respect thing and no
one really wants to fight him and this
uh and I don't think we're gonna show it
but so he he's destroyed everyone that
genuine was supposed to be one of the
stuff's fights doesn't get touched right
yeah so then I think Django then he's
ranked in the top 15 and it's kind of
unheard of they go all right nobody
whatever 11 through three wanna fight
you here's the number two guy in the
world Gilbert Burns okay so he fights
Gilbert Burns and Gilbert Burns dorino
is a he is his background he's a
world-class uh Jiu Jitsu guy like
15-time World Champ in the ghee out of
ghee but his striking has gotten better
he had that fight when we watched with
Camaro
beat the [ __ ] out of him so he he's one
of the best in the world so they give
hamzat him and you're like Jesus Christ
man that's a big jump up but hums that's
a monster but nobody else will fight him
no one survived him so that's why they
did it and they're trying to Fast Track
him because y'all see he has the chops
to get it done so they give it to him
and in that and it's it's a long fight
to go to the decision 500 or three round
decision that's why we're not gonna
watch it but you'll see a different side
of homs that we're like oh he's is human
if he wants to be so in that fight he
does he throws caution to the wind and
just is in a phone booth and just he
gets you see him get hit a few times he
you know his takedowns because uh
Gilbert Burns can you know actually his
takedown defense really good so he
doesn't really get him down like it's a
straight up it's a war and so the first
round he destroys him and second round
he probably lost like Gilbert land some
big shots third rounds he beats them and
I think the fame and like the hype got
to Hamza because as Gilbert's walked
into the lock on hamzat's on top of the
cage like this smiling and laughing with
his buddies and you're like Dude where's
the where's the the chechny kid who's
ready to go here so that's the only kind
of [ __ ] in the Army you've seen and his
coaches between rounds are like what are
you doing and is that number 11. is that
fighting this is that was fight number
11. no he so I think this isn't this
fight number 12 of his his 12th it's
gonna be his 12th fight right total but
this is why I think his fifth fighting
you see this next oh so and that's why
we're watching Nate Diaz next because
the next pay-per-view is hamzat who's
the Golden Boy The chestnut Golden Boy
and he's undefeated undefeated versus
Nate Diaz and so all the UFC's trying to
do here so just so you're aware Nate
Diaz has one fight left on his contract
yes he's been trying to resign him he's
like nope I just want to get out of my
contract and go fight Jake Paul and
Danny goes cool say less but we're a
business so before you leave you gotta
walk through [ __ ] chechnyan fire to
get out that door here's Hamza doesn't
make a lot of sense homside I think is a
is a plus two 2200 favorite like which
is unheard of in mixed martial arts so
you don't give Nadia's a chance
personally I do I do because and maybe
it's a bit of the you know I've been
following the UFC so long and Nate Diaz
like he he's not easy to finish he's a
tougher customer I'm gonna tell you
something right now the last person we
talked about was that Usman fight right
and I was on I was on my online and you
know my my online on Twitch Eric Griffin
gaming we were talking about it and I
thought he was going to lose the fight
you know why because there is something
about the the pressure
to be undefeated
to break Anderson Silva's all-time
record to break to break the record
there's a lot of pressure the pressure
the hype of being like people are
telling you you're great the pound for
pound number one guy in the world you
gotta be he alluded to that he did say
he was a lot and Dana goes I overcome
realized the pressure that she's under
yeah he's almost more it's not that he's
happy he lost but he's more relaxed my
only caveat with that is yes he lost
that fight
I'm a leon Edwards fan if they're gonna
do the rematch he's not gonna win that
rematch like you say uzban's gonna come
back yeah
dominated that fight he took it so he
got taken down the first round like
that's not normal and then after that he
Molly want that dude Molly want them and
then took his eye off the prize for one
second shellac gets knocked out that's
the highest level that's why I was about
to say that's the game right that's the
game so it reminds me actually all these
individual sports like that because golf
is the same way you know you could be
like you know going all the way and then
you like double bogey on the last hole
and yeah and you're too good so that's
right but what I'm saying is I do feel
like the pressure and believe in your
own hype is a thing and what I'm and I
feel like if this guy is standing on the
uh thing doing that thing on this fight
he gonna get caught by Nate Diaz I agree
100 with you but my only caveat with
that I said the exact same thing when he
fought Gilbert Burns I thought he was
gonna Molly wob Gilbert rooms only this
terrible fight for Gilbert it was a
fight man you're like oh that's right
that's why Gilbert's ranked number two
in the world but but Hamza comes from a
camp that is one of the best in the
world I guarantee you they don't let him
fight like that they have to be here I
think and and preparation preparation
sticking to the game plan being a
professional because all right you beat
Gilbert you barely got by that these
other guys You're Gonna Lose do you
think that so he still won even though
he had his worst outing he still won so
the hype's still there the Nate Diaz
thing is tough to me because
even if hamzat destroys Nate in the
first or second round you can't give him
a title shot because you still got Leon
Edwards and Usman to go okay do you
think that this because his last fight
was the Gilbert fight right yes okay so
you think that because of the toughness
of that Gilbert fight that uh that it
went as long as it did do you think that
was enough wake-up call for him to be
like well now I got to go into this Nate
Diaz fight with a whole different
mentality correct and I think that's
what he's going to do yeah so if he is
the truth yeah and his team is as good
as we think he knows he can't that he he
got very lucky that night it was Gilbert
because if it was Colby Covington if
it's Usman if it's Leon Edwards he
doesn't win that fight I was gonna say
like do you think that if he would have
like ran through him you know grappled
him got some lucky whatever with skill
and he took him out he did a shot he
would have he would have come he might
have come into this an idea fight with a
little bit like I'm the man and he would
have lost this when he would have lost
so so I think he's a good one oh I like
that I like that so I'm kind of 50 50
right now yeah so but the Nate Diaz
fight is interesting because you know
Nate Diaz you know and Dana alluded to
this he's like you know he's won one
fight of the last like six years so the
fight as far as fight like Dana got so
much backlash when he made this fight it
doesn't make a ton of sense oh and Tom's
I think ranked number three in the world
Nate dizzy isn't even ranked but Nate
Diaz is way more famous so as a business
I get it as a fan I don't get it because
Dana's going okay yeah he can leave Nate
go go fight Jake Paul that makes sense
to make all the money in the world but
you have this massive fan base we want
that fan base to jump on board with
Hamza so before you leave well before
you go fight this model oh so this is
like when Hulk Hogan fought the Ultimate
Warrior yes 100 right yeah remember that
that was great and then Hulk Hogan lost
a belt and it was like you know and and
even if 10 of the fans go over it builds
Hamza that's all they're trying to do I
hear from you that
um you I I don't think you don't agree
with this fight no I I think it's [ __ ]
up to do it to a guy Nate Diaz who's
been a team player and you know and has
has was a The Ultimate Fighter winner
his his Conor McGregor fights you know
the two fights there like he's done a
lot for the company the way you repay
the guys to be completely honest they're
going to be a worse matchup in the world
for him his last fight to tell you what
I'm going out because are you rooting
for him
uh I am yeah yeah in a weird way I am I
and I like stairs I get it and I like
chaos like I think well this would be I
think it'd be hilarious if he beat uh uh
Hamza messed up the UFC's plans I think
it's hilarious because then he dips out
and goes fights Jake Paul it's hilarious
to me yeah but that being said there
could not be a worse matchup for him oh
it's a man
wow so so the guy he's fighting the idea
is the The Legend they did so Nate Diaz
and I've heard of this guy I'm sure yeah
so he got very famous obviously off
Connor but before that was The Ultimate
Fighter winner he's always had a huge
fan base but he comes you know his older
brother Nick Diaz is a MMA royalty too
from Strikeforce that comes to the UFC
he had he had that fight you would
probably know the scene where
um he laid down all his financial and
silver he laid down oh [ __ ] oh he was
high as [ __ ] yeah he just lays down like
one of the biggest fights of all time he
just lays in the middle and pretends
he's just chilling like there's just him
and his brother just have this Savage
fan basement so he's the little brother
he's damn good you know he's following
some hard times I think part of the
problem is the Diaz brothers have
they've never adapted to the to the game
so leg kicks not their thing boxing Jiu
Jitsu wrestling kicks adapting being
well-rounded they just it's not their
thing but they're damn good at boxing
they're damn good at Jitsu but the the
US the level of the UFC fighter has
evolved and they never evolved but they
have Granite Chans they're tough as
nails if you give them a chance they're
gonna choke you out or knock you out and
the difference between Nate Diaz and
hamzat is Nate Diaz is a volume puncher
so for every two punches hamzat throws
Nate throws ten you're gonna see on the
copy strike numbers it goes decision
Nate Diaz fans are gonna be pissed I'm
like well he landed 300 punches it's
like I know but hom thought when he
throws it counts that's the difference
let's take another little break chat
with my boy Eric because listen man
right now if you're filling anything out
online your personal information listen
between my family the busy life I got I
got enough to worry about I want to
worry about someone hacking and stealing
all my information my identity it's not
good man but I know exactly how to
protect myself all right I know exactly
with my friends at Allstate ever heard
of them that's right Allstate are the
best in the biz at identity protection
the best identity protection from a
brand you can trust all state baby
that's right so much of life is logging
in to your digital lives that's why
Allstate developed an identity
protection product that protects your
Digital Life just like you do your
physical life with Allstate I didn't any
protection they'll reimburse you up to a
million buckaroos for out-of-pocket
expenses lost wages legal fees also
cover money stolen from your bank
accounts 401ks hsas and tax returns at
Allstate they have been protecting the
things people love for over 90 freaking
years we got you covered man what I love
about Allstate's protection is I don't
have to worry about it peace of mind
they cover the whole family kids girl we
got it covered man it's the new age
things new age of crime the stealing
your identity stealing digitally that's
what they're doing we're on our phones
24 7. so you need the best protection
possible that's all state so when you
think of identity protection think
Allstate identity protection to find out
if your employer offers Allstate
identity protection head to aip.com
if not get a 30-day free trial at
aip.com shop that's 30 days free one
last time that's aip.com shop protect
yourself now let's get back to the
program guys let's take a little break
because there's one thing you know about
me I worry about your wieners I care
about your wiener I really do and that's
why my friends at Blue too they really
give me that Turbo Charge in the bedroom
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers same active ingredients of
Viagra Cialis but in chewable tablets at
a fraction of the cost do you like to
save money like to make sure your wiener
works all right Bluetooth got you
covered man you can take the mini time
day or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready when it's time to go you have to
worry about it all right the process
super simple sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with a licensed Medical
Professional and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days best part it's all done online no
visits to the doctor office no awkward
conversations you don't have to wait in
line at the pharmacy all right everyone
knows you're picking up these wiener
pills it's weird man it's awkward not
anymore delivers straight to your door
discrete little package nobody has to
know Bluetooth is made in the U.S of a
all right so if you could benefit from
something like this a little extra
confident for your weiner game all right
when it's time to perform Bluetooth can
help you guys eyes out chew it and do it
baby you all right and I got a special
deal for all you guys watching the show
right now try Bluetooth free I'm gonna
use the promo code shop at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
Bluetooth
b-l-u-e-choo.com promo code shop schab
to receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details important
safety information and I thank Bluetooth
for being part of the show so here's
Nate Diaz I just hear how you're talking
about this I don't I don't think you
giving ideas a shot at all it's gonna be
tough there's a reason there's a reason
to do this to be very tough there's a
reason homeboys minus 2200. that's
unfucking heard of in our sport I feel
like I'm gonna put 100 on DS that's not
a bad idea at all you know what I mean
right I'm rooting for it I'm rooting for
him and I'm not because I love when a
guy's his come up and this is hamza's
come up see homicide wouldn't even allow
a fight to be like no no no no no like
I'm looking at this
no no no no no no it's a night
and also this is what yours is
2012. yeah like like he's fighting Gray
Maynard here 2013 there you go yeah you
know what the game's evolved I was just
about to say I see how this this looks
old school to me this is old school
because like I'm like they don't they
don't do this anymore so so this will be
the equivalent of me showing you Patrick
Mahomes and then be like check out Bart
Starr and you'd be like oh okay yeah
he's good
[ __ ] up you know like they're in
leather helmets like the UFC is so new
like the advancement is insane like you
look at women's sports in fighting like
how far they've come it's nuts in two
years is it illegal to grab the fence
yes okay you'll get away with it once
you do it again they're gonna take a
point right right but he couldn't have
used it yet you know so oh filthy that
looked I look very like a skilled move
yeah and Nate's very like his background
is Jiu-Jitsu in a ghee very traditional
and then phenomenal boxing so Andre Ward
imagine me when these guys in a bar and
like oh nightmare you know what I mean
like just I'd still rather meet both of
them than Hamza in a bar all right let
me ask you this about Nate Diaz I mean
his arms look his arms are very lanky
yeah he has reached again he's a volume
guy but he doesn't have power not really
yeah I could see that not really I could
see that yeah because he landed like a
bunch of shots on Connor you know and
then eventually Connor shot and got
choked out but anyone at like comes out
lands those punches you're there's no
way man you're waking up in the in the
Green Room you know it's it's just a
different animal dude so again and to be
this guy's a Grappler this other guy
yeah gray manual his background's uh
wrestling yeah but you know this is a
finish of Nate Diaz now because you know
this show we want to make excited and
show you the highlights yeah yeah yeah
you know we have to go back to 2013 to
give you a highlight from the ideas like
yeah in a second it's been a tough goal
yeah oh man yeah you really are down on
Nate Diaz man for for the matchup 100
like it's a nightmare well I'm saying
even in general I think that you feel
like the Diaz
that like he could have done a lot more
for himself if he would have adopted
some other things I feel like you're
kind of down on his uh skill set well
his unbox I'm not again him and his
brother train with Andre Ward who you
know top five of all time and like they
spar with him and like boxing was like
don't get a Twist man like when Nate
fights Jake Paul that's a long night in
the office for Jake Paul like that's a
Jake Paul should be an underdog in that
fight like Nate Diaz can [ __ ] box and
his range volume cardio like as far as
box boxing goes as far as MMA goes it's
tough for me to get excited about the
current Nate Diaz he fights once every
two years once a year you know so it's
tough to to get excited about that
because you got to be active to be a
real player in the game oh this guy's
not in it anymore and he was a stud uh
Mania was a monster man you could tell
at this point right now this other
dude's like I I I'm he's not even in it
anymore no oh man that's tough that's a
tough dude right there because in this
whole moment right here when all this is
happening he is trying with all his uh
stuff that come all his will is to he's
keeping him up his will kept him up
right there that's how tough he is and
yeah you know Rashad Evans so there's
that was his brother in this corner
there his brother's always in this
corner uh Nick Diaz who's a legend man
super legend like they're Legends it's
just in 2022 I get it the game's evolved
yeah
I get it he's fighting the number one
guy of all now this is where the Nate
Diaz
kind of trajectory blows through the
[ __ ] roof because he's fighting Conor
McGregor now let me ask you this now
did it blow up because of Conor
McGregor's fame or was it and he beat
him or was it because
um he was just better
you know what I mean that's a good
question so we're actually watching the
second fight which Connor wins correct
so over to the first fight we're
yeah that's fine so so when he fights
Connor remember Conor is the biggest
thing to ever happen in the sport
they were kind of the perfect you know
it's it's the Spider-Man Venom thing to
correlate the comic books so he kind of
had an adversary and Nate Diaz is the
opposite of Conor econom beats most guys
before he walks in the Octagon right
right Nate doesn't give a [ __ ] that's
one thing you love about Nate like
telling a [ __ ] about fame money he just
loves to fight so with the Conor it's
like the Conor haters all jumped on the
Nate train Connor's fan base was going
for Connor so you had this perfect
rivalry happening you know and this is
the the first fight he's more skilled
Connor Connor so this fight's also at
170. Connor's not 170. especially back
then now maybe but back then Connor's is
the to me the best fighter that's ever
entered the Octagon was Connor at 155
when he fought Eddie Alvarez that's the
best fighter I've ever seen in my life
gotcha hands down so at 170 you know and
a short notice too so it was like he's
the bigger guy so you'll see Conor's
Landing shots and dropping them but he's
just not big enough to put him away and
gotcha that's an idea especially like go
ahead and beat on me man I'll wait
around because this is his natural
weight class yeah yeah okay now he
originally came into the UFC when he's
younger at 155 one Ultimate Fighter at
155 in gradually as he got older started
fighting that welterweight but Nate Diaz
is not a small dude you know what you
know what's funny about you man the
things you don't say are just as loud as
the things that you do say meaning
you know oh like my Expressions no I'm
saying like when you're talking about
someone I also hear the thing other
things you're saying about them yeah you
know what I mean it's like you know
because like it's like you think
Connor's a better fighter and he put
himself in this situation and a lot of
it has to do with the business of the
UFC I mean you know so it's like you
know I so I feel from like talking to
you and all these things I feel like the
UFC you know that they the one they
don't have enough Fighters
okay in the different weight classes and
then we're not necessarily getting the
best matchups that we could possibly get
correct you're 100 correct but also and
then fans are like oh the reason why
shop might be a little salty towards uh
Nate because we had an issue when I
worked for Showtime I was the my job was
to sell the fans and the boxing fans on
why Conor McGregor might have a chance
to beat Floyd Mayweather I got paid to
convince people yeah tough kick tough
kick tough kick dude the odds were not
on my side but that was my paid gig to
do that some come up with every kind of
explanation why things do it so I you
know went on the tour went to the fight
I was the Conor McGregor expert well
Nate Diaz because they have their issues
viewed me as team Connor so when we go
to the and I'm just filling in why
people think I'm salty so after that
fight I'm walking through
it's all boxing fans and they're talking
[ __ ] to me like whatever I see Nate now
we're part of a alumni man like I was on
The Ultimate Fighter I was the top 10
UFC heavyweight there's no other UFC
representatives there so I see a
familiar face it'd be like if you go to
a party and it's all actors and you see
the comic from us the store or somebody
yeah get around you'd be like oh thank
God there's one of me yeah yeah I have
actually somebody to talk to so I see
Nan go oh thank God there's another
there's a guy part of my crew so I go
what's up bro and goes nah man I [ __ ]
told you I'm like I look around like
what what are you talking about he said
[ __ ] you don't know box I'm like whoa
dude this was a gig bro you don't know
[ __ ] about that and then I was like
dude calm down what are you talking
about and I said and then I get
defensive because there's a fireworks so
I go hold up hold up I said he was gonna
land punches he landed punches bro yeah
and that just set him off and then he
wanted to square up and I'm like okay
and then my Showtime boss was like you
touch him you're gonna lose all the jobs
dude yeah cannot have that yeah and I
was like yeah of course we can so then
you know the the internet gets a hold of
it and they you know manufacture it like
I was talking [ __ ] to him there's no
[ __ ] talking with that being said like
to me it's like I get it there's
animosity because he thinks I'm Connor's
team I like Nate Diaz I don't give a
[ __ ] about any of that that was would
that bring you back into five years ago
you and Nate Diaz absolutely not I don't
want to fight that Savage absolutely not
dude yeah with your cushy-ass life yeah
hell no hell no
it's like he's like
he's like trying to I I can barely train
for the Tough Mudder let alone a fight
bro you yeah you pulled your hammy
against Chappelle yeah yeah racing into
my other [ __ ] comic friend get ready
for it a cage fight all right okay so I
understand a little bit that makes sense
it does make sense but I do feel like
you know you I mean I it just you know
as somebody coming in late to this I I
am now he has a wrap so people think the
bees like Beyonce's like they think her
fan base is insane bro The Beehive bro
that beehive dude talk about the Nick
Hive dude the amount of hate I am like
whoa I like him chill I defend him we're
all good me and him are good ooh
yeah so again this is Connor you know
doing his damn thing I forget I forget
you know I wasn't really into it so I
it's like funny to see how Connor was
doing the
you know the the UFC stuff yeah
right yeah I mean because he just did
like a little a ballet spin move and I'm
like okay I forgot this guy's like a
fighter fighter oh dude in his prime oh
like like if Mayweather was in a ring
with him yeah he would destroy him God
yeah and they're talking and they're
talking about running back so Connor's
you know you've seen him slipping
punches and doing the damn thing but you
know he's finding a bigger guy you can
tell how much bigger look how much
bigger Nate is yeah yeah he is now this
is what's impressive so this is the
first fight and Connor loses gets choked
out Connor beats him in the second fight
dude beats him that's what a badass
Conor McGregor is
he's talking [ __ ] too he's like oh yep
what Connor like squares up and and you
know Nate Diaz is a really good boxer
Connor's slipping Landing wow look at
his face him up yeah with that that left
hand that would have been the one right
there if he would have connected that
yep but again to Nate's credit like he's
just like he's impossible to put away so
with the the homsat fight you got to
wonder if Hans then there's Jim Norton
ringside if hamzat you know if he's
Landing Big Shots which I promise you
aren't going to put any ideas out at
first he's gonna eat a couple big
[ __ ] chest and shots In Harm's eyes
he's gonna be like oh [ __ ] because if
you have that oh [ __ ] moment against
Nate he'll finish you man he'll get your
neck okay let me ask you this then so
they're fighting in Nate Diaz's weight
class yes 170. if Nate had to come down
to 155 Connor wrecks him both times I
think so
gotcha makes sense because you look at
you look at this fine you asked who's
more like Technical and skill wise like
look at Connor slip and jump drive and
like he can't touch him and like Conor's
countering he's throwing kicks he's
mixing it up he's just landing at will
but he just doesn't have the same KO
power that he has at 55. yeah and then
Connor gets tired too yeah he's tired
he's tired and then again Nate doesn't
get tired yeah I was just about to say
this other guy doesn't look he's just
gonna if the strategy is just wear him
down it's working yep and and he just
keep he's like the [ __ ] Stockton
Terminator
no dude but notice how it's not wobbling
or nothing yeah I know but it'd be just
but I'm saying in the ease which Connor
just slipped that uppercut in
my face is just
and then eventually lands one and it
puts him you know on Sixth Street now
back in the AP we say queer Street and
that's how I changed it to Sixth Street
that's called
keeping up with the times you're just
evolving yeah I mean you're evolving now
if you watch the newest King of the
scene I'll harm the pain I'm Wonder
Woman so I'm not losing fans yeah
well if you're good to be on the patreon
though yeah you gotta be on that what we
call them the Cubs on the pages
yeah you look at Nate Diaz Corners
Chrome Gracie is Jake Shields you know
he has he's just the who soon is Corner
man
yeah and the thing is about Nate is he's
a good dude man you know what I'm saying
he's just he just wants to fight he's a
fight brother runs [ __ ] triathlons
and fighter they're just Legends man oh
he just he had a moment there he was
like that's all you got yeah and you and
you think our boy Rogan smokes weed bro
Nate Diaz and his brother see you see
now this is alarming Nate now Conor
shoots for a takedown which I've never
seen before so he rolls out of this
Guillotine and you know when it comes to
grappling like Conor's probably purplish
belt but you know you're talking about a
straight Caesar Gracie black belt like
Kim shooting was the the beginning to
the end for him like so like like if
you're gonna say oh yeah but he was
tired getting hit so he Taps yeah
and then he gets on the mic and goes I'm
not surprised [ __ ]
um
and this was like you know one of the
biggest moments in UFC history
he says I'm not surprised and then my
specialist called you'd be surprised you
see this you see how I use that okay
ah have you since uh squashed your beef
with this guy yeah I love I love Nate
yeah I mean we haven't ran into each
other
um you know usually he's in Venice a lot
when I live down there I see him a lot
more but you know you know part of the
problem is I'm you know when I first
started doing all this coming
no I don't think maybe listen Maybe on
his end you know I don't know how he
operates like maybe he just he's like a
baby elephant he just never you know
forgets things I don't give a I have no
animosity tourism I get bigger fish to
fry
and he does too so I I assume he's not
even thinking about it oh these guys
shots in yeah man oh that was the one
right there and that's the I think
that's the moment he was like okay yeah
and times have changed like Connor's You
Know Rich and happy now and you know
broke his leg he's on a yacht posting
picture of him getting sucked off by his
wife so it's like things have changed
yeah weird Flex right to post a video if
you can yeah suck off by your wife like
it's your wife now it's deflective it's
like Rihanna that's like holy [ __ ] now I
will say this I watch everyone's like
you believe this I'm like God that guy's
living he's on a shot like he's in
Mykonos I'm like holy [ __ ] that guy's
what some people are looking at that
they're like what are you doing with
your wife
[Laughter]
yeah people are more upset yeah [ __ ]
Connor
wife this is ridiculous all right so
then all right so then
so then you know Nate wins what's Nate's
last fight that he fought he fought uh
Leon Edwards and uh Leon beat his ass
the last 30 seconds because Nate's so
[ __ ] tough lyanna Woods doing his
thing you saw good Leon is and then Nate
lands one big shot boom wobbles Leon but
there's 30 seconds left clock stops
Leon dominated the entire fights for the
last 30 seconds so then the narrative
there because Nate's a more famous
fighter people oh if there's 30 seconds
left there's a street fight Leon would
have lost that so it actually was a
black eye no pun intended it was a black
guy in Leon Edwards like oh man you you
would have got finished man Leon's like
bro I I won for four rounds four minutes
so he's like all right whatever man well
there's zealots they're some of the fans
I get it I understand that you like your
guy you like your guy
so then this is uh I'm not Nate Diaz
next yeah
yeah Saturday this is the one next
Saturday yep next Saturday it's Saturday
it's a big boy man but I think you're
gonna watch and I I bet you know just
because the human thing to do is you
don't root for the guy who's the minus
2200 favorite like there would be
something magical in Nate Diaz winning
and that's why I want to see him win and
it also
like he beats the man like they're
setting him up dude I gotta be honest
they're [ __ ] they're gonna be a
bigger setup in the history of the UFC
like they don't want him to go on to
accomplish great things so Hamza if he
were to lose his fight he's gonna be
fine so and I'm a homslot fan I'm so
honest Chechen nuts yeah but I'm going
for Nate Diaz man I hope he wins I hope
he wins and goes on and makes 50 million
dollars fighting Jake Paul which I think
you know it's a good chance to win that
well this is well then that's what's on
the line for Nadia yeah Nate Diaz beats
this guy oh and then he just sails off
into the sunset just walks out of the
ring like see ya yep and then he gets
his you know he gets his fine final big
payday never has to do anything ever
again run marathon smoke weed do
whatever you want you think that would
be a big payday him versus Jake Paul oh
the biggest payday now I think
regardless whether he loses his fight
whether he gets knocked out finished
submitted doesn't matter I think that
Jake Paul fights big no matter what
there's a few guys in the UFC Nate Diaz
BJ Penn for the longest time they're
showing guys who can lose mosveldal and
we don't give well [ __ ] they could lose
six fights and they can be a main event
fight for a title and the fans aren't
upset Nate it seems like this guy oh
Nate it's one of those guys well it
seems like because he doesn't cheat the
fans
no he he but he's also not fake like
there's no that's what I'm saying that's
what people like like he throws a middle
finger to the fan he went to the UFC uh
pi and just pissed on in the building I
just I don't know I'm trying I really
don't know I mean I'm just taking it all
in all in you know I think it's a lot
it's a lot for you I think because he
had that really good fight his last
fight I think he's going to be more
focused and ready me too but at the same
time I feel like Nate is really
motivated to leave the UFC on a high I
think he probably feels insulted by Big
Time by this I think he feels like set
up I think you know I think it feels
like oh you won't let me take me out
like that but I also feel like his pride
is at stake right now this is gonna be a
great fight how fascinating is it now
yeah aren't you into it yeah tune in one
over that's why we do it yeah guys hope
you enjoyed the show you're the best
brother boom real quick comes out on uh
Nate who wins oh you know what it's
tough uh I think it's gonna be tough for
Nate to win but I feel like you think
you can get it done I think I I think he
it's a long shot but I think with his
experience and skill I think he could
get it done I think he's gonna uh even
if he were to lose I think he's gonna be
a better fight than people think yeah I
think so too but a chance to win you
know at the same time though I also feel
like this guy's just a Savage oh dude
and I feel like he's gonna go for the
grappling right away big time I feel
like I feel like uh hamzaad's strategy
is going to be to get to break he is on
the ground and never let him get off the
ground agree and he's not worried about
his traditional Brazilians yeah he's not
worrying about all that so all right
guys hope you enjoyed it until next time